Tanna mojo and a Jake Paul may be
engaged few of me but one person who's
seemingly not celebrating tannaz ex
Bella Thorne Bella shared her reaction
to the news on Instagram posting at this
clip of her rolling her eyes with the
caption my response to Tana Manzo's
engagement is on that weird [ __ ] Bella
and it didn't end there she also posted
these two close-up shots of her
tear-filled eyes along with the caption
when your ex gets engaged now it's
unclear if they're happy or sad tears
but Tana did respond to the post in the
comments section writing simply OMG i
never fake cry Bella was publicly in an
open relationship with rapper mod Sun
and Tana for nearly a year but in
February she announced she was no longer
seeing Tana and despite her tear-filled
post Bella had a sweet message for Tana
on her birthday sharing this shot of her
with her ex on a boat riding through
thick and thin I love you Tana happy
bday you beautiful beautiful special
girl tannaz birthday followed a
fun-filled weekend in Las Vegas where
fellow youtuber Jake Paul popped the
question
during her bday bash at Dre's nightclub
that photo take this
[Applause]